yeah no I'm fascinated by how open you
are with your I I love my fans I like to
be recognized I don't like to touch
that's why I'm into the Hologram
business now but you don't have to talk
about which is incredible yeah but just
to be places without actually going
places you've invited people over to
your house yeah I like to touch
okay
aren't you married as a girlfriend I'm
engaged no he's engaged that's hopeful
do you have a date uh no not yet we're
just enjoying yeah what do you say to
people and I'm not I'm not judging in
any way she's young right yes is that
that's good right of course yeah yeah
but people give you hell for that well
sometimes oh you're talking about the
internet that's a whole nother League
yeah that's where you live the internet
in your lawn in real life nobody's ever
had any kind of uh anything but like
giving us flowers and being very lovely
about the producer on this show Rich has
a very young I bet you this
I just turned I just turned 50 she's 23.
okay how long have you been in this
business
31 years so she when you started as a
comedian she didn't even exist
and neither did I quite frankly
um but uh that's that's bizarre do you
ever think about that do you ever go you
know oh there's a whole routine in my in
this above it all special about our
relationship we are so very
self-deprecating about it we have a lot
of fun with it so if people watch the
show then yes when is the date sometime
next fall and uh right when she finishes
College
I wish she was here today because I do
too she was she's awesome what does she
do for a living she's a certified
Pilates instructor
does health and wellness and she's an
incredibly gifted singer which that's
like not her first love but
singer-songwriter why don't you put her
on AGT
she wants to actually do something like
that she's like I would like to give
that a go I know somebody there I I know
you do very close but yeah of course you
can't I can't but we could get her on
AGT oh what kind of music is she
pursuing that as a career do you want
her to pursue that as a career she just
loves she's one of those people that
organically loves writing music and
singing she has like she's a she's a one
take performer she never has to it's
kind of incredible like a Phenom
listening to her sing but it's she
doesn't have that like I in comedy was
like I I want to meet these goals and
she's more like ah wherever it takes me
I'm kind of cool with whatever how do
you meet at 23 year old how do you meet
where do you meet I used to uh host
every Friday night for two years I had a
uh like a code names or running charades
game night at my house and we'd have
like 20 or 30 people come over and if
you had nothing to do on a Friday me and
my buddy Kyle would host it and we would
do like I said Mafia or code names or
board games or well you did that used to
go to somebody's house and play Mafia
right Mafia is like no it was a scooter
oh okay yeah so so so how did you
recruit people for these games no
everybody knew it was kind of so my
buddy Kyle Newman had run it for about
three or four years he had a another kid
and then he was like okay so can
somebody else take over for a little bit
I was like I'll host it at my house and
then I just ended up meeting her through
hosting game nights so how long have you
been going out going going out yeah oh
no we've been together five years so now
we're engaged after being together five
years eighteen wow yeah
wow yeah it's legal no I'm not I'm not
judging I'm going wow
wow it's legal no it is legal were you
was there any trepidation well I mean I
wanted to meet your parents you know
pretty much right away just let them get
to know me and see that it's like and
and by the way and we talk about this
and it's in the show we didn't even
think it would work you know we were
like okay every you know philosophies
change things change but at this point
in my life I mean I'm like I'm eternally
and I'm the guy that's like at one in
the morning I'm up with an idea and I'm
writing and I'm getting things done and
she's like in bed at eight o'clock
because she gets up and does her Pilates
classes at five or six so we we evened
each other out she calls herself an old
lady and I'm like you know constantly in
that uh you know 20 year old mode you're
probably closer to her mother's age how
old is her mother I don't even know
closer to 60. oh so then you're not how
old are you 50. oh wow was that a tough
age for you no no I think when I turned
50 it was tough when I turned uh well
now I'm really old I'm going to be 67
this year were you like a forever
Bachelor like you thought you were never
gonna get married oh no you always want
more than anything I wanted to do stand
up and I wanted to have a family
[Music]